austin texas host of the annual south by
southwest festival it's one of the
biggest events in the music world
calendar this year it featured over 2
200 acts
among the big name german acts here are
milky chants they're up early for a
morning session with local radio station
kgsr it's their first time performing at
the festival but they're already big in
the u.s where their hit stolen dance
went platinum
there are just some songs that you hear
and you know immediately are going to be
huge and i could just just tell it was
immediately catchy resonated with my
ears and i knew that our audience would
love it so we've been playing it since
may of 2014.
many casual fans have only just learned
that the band are german either way
their sound is going down a treat and
their style too i like them a lot and i
like his hair yeah we love his hair
they're really good and they're going to
make it really far especially in the u.s
there's a special base at the festival
for german performers this year 22 acts
are gracing the stage some received
subsidies from a government arts funding
agency back home
it's like a christmas present it's
really great because there are some who
couldn't otherwise afford to come
and they're not always in a position to
take part in promotional events like
this so they really need any support we
can offer
for relative unknowns like berlin-based
oracles that support could mean the big
breakthrough
while hoping to attract interest from
u.s record labels the indie pop
merchants are careful not to count their
chickens before they hatch
it's easier to go into it without
expectations and just to let yourself be
surprised by whatever happens
and not to go to a foreign country like
the us with specific expectations
when it comes to after dark
entertainment in austin visitors are
spoilt for choice
in the evenings festival goers check out
the clubs in the hope of discovering new
talent
your girl picks up the flight lightsink
band talking to turtles
normally a duo this evening floyd zivas
is performing without his partner
claudia gurler
lovely old committed wife
the folk singers all too familiar with
the hustle and bustle of the austin
scene so he's glad to be performing in
more intimate venues
oh
whoa
you mess around with your cold growl
in public of course it's great if
there's someone in the audience who
could help you out in the future but
there's so many bands playing here
people just go from one concert to the
next
i haven't given her all that much
thought
but he's in for a surprise his
performance looks to have won him some
gigs in turkey
it was absolutely wonderful we i'd i'd
never heard of them before so
um you know hopefully it's spans like
this that we want to bring to turkey and
maybe do a showcase or maybe do a
smaller festival
with these bands
and you never know because it's very
funny that um
sometimes certain names suddenly explode
in countries like turkey and then take
over the whole of uh eastern europe
when we tell him later he's delighted
there's some great news i'd love to go
and play in turkey
time to check back in with one of the
festival's top acts milky chance after
headlining one of austin's biggest shows
they'll be setting off on an extensive
u.s tour
it's the longest tour we've done so far
the longest we will be
doing we're off to a really good start
we're definitely into it
whether it's a warm-up performance for a
tour or simply an opportunity to network
with some major names this year's south
by southwest festival has been a major
success for german bands